security concerns are causing new delays
for international inspectors trying to
get to the site of an alleged chemical
weapons attack in Syria this morning
they say they were shot at adumim in the
government stronghold of Aleppo
thousands of Syrians gathered last night
to celebrate Syria's National Day in a
show of defiance against Western powers
Seth Doane is in Aleppo in northern
Syria
good morning despite the US UK and
France targeting Syria with more than
100 airstrikes in recent days on Tuesday
Syrians celebrated their historic
independence from France opera and folk
dancing may not be how you'd imagine
spending an evening in Aleppo but
Syria's government wants to show
strength in the wake of those strikes
the city in northern Syria was divided
by fierce fighting as the government
battled rebel forces here at the heart
of the city the citadel was held by
Assad's forces and never lost that's
where this concert was and where we met
this social worker this is reminiscent
of another time of the great time of
Syria before the world before the world
was many but not far from the singing
and dancing war still rages rival rebel
groups here in northern Syria have been
fighting each other in the countryside
to the west and southwest if you're
Russian and Syrian airstrikes have been
pounding rebel positions in Eid Lib
Syrians at least here in government
controlled territory are celebrating
their recent wins on the battlefield and
trying to look forward for CBS this
morning Seth Doane Aleppo sat down
making us all proud by continuing that
amazing reporting from war-torn Syria